okay so here's the here's the thing
video we had we've had our teaser
trailer for good I promise it was
initially sort of watched with our
Kickstarter campaign and then months
after Kickstarter was over then we
uploaded it to youtube and it that's
been there just kind of sitting there
for like two years currently we have a
guy that's working on the official
trailer whatever but you know here we
are working for 30 days away we still
haven't launched the trailer yet possum
it is this a good thing or bad thing
Sears a golden nugget I don't
know how I missed this i was about to
leave here and forget two things you
guys got to do the trailer this is
wonderful that's not done yet this is
the official trailer you kind of pick a
target that makes sense that will drive
audiences to your screening offer to
them as an exclusive all the films do
this you know and then maybe maybe we
can tap into the downtown independent
network as well you know how they are
possibly offering you up a couple media
outlets most of the theater do that they
have friendlies press that they work
with place that trailer with them is
exclusive and then you have all the
information of how to purchase the
tickets in the time has to be embedded
in that trailer exclusive let's say this
is when the film is playing please come
out and check out the tickets that's
your exclusive and then you blast that
out once it runs you blast it out to
everybody in the network check out the
trailer in advance of my film coming out
this is when dude that's important who
are some of the people we should be
thinking on you know you know here we
already have a small logo LA Weekly uh
la weekly website you know LA Times
Brand X local local local local local
news Culver City News not if they have a
very good social online presence online
presence and or maybe like a very fish
bowl le verre de NOS angeles there's
also the you know the the LA type of
tastemaker websites that are out there
right now you know that's a yeah the
elias and these types you know these
folks and you look at the list of the
local los angeles ones you offer it to
them as
of and you get the support and again
that goes back to the barber story if
it's not a relationship that downtown
has it's not a relationship EU has the
entryways of potential partnership now
that's not the only thing I mean dude
you n do we literally give them the file
so they upload absolutely absolutely you
make the agreement first you work out
the deal first you say here's my film we
have a one-week run let's work out a
deal where you can post this on the mate
on your main page and write how long one
day they get to one day how long no no
it's only a few hours it's a few hours
you know of the day and then after that
you can put it everywhere you know you
just work out the window maybe three
hours you get you get a jump on this
because I'm we're sending this out no
matter what we're sending this trailer
out to everybody just like an avatar
avatar I don't know what their trailer
campaign was but you know they put it
somewhere maybe they did an imax thing
first you know you know who did it
recently someone someone put something
on imax and it was an imax and they held
it offline and then they put it out
everywhere like the next week and then
someone else did it in itunes only and
then they put it out everywhere you know
you're doing the same thing your studio
you're an independent studio you guys
your filmmakers independent filmmaker
weren't theaters that's why I'm telling
you you got to think like these machines
because you are you are mini version of
that machine so use that but also what I
remind you is the poster as opposed to
run anywhere yet um well we've just put
out the wrong channels you know that
that's another asset that's a first look
pick up Entertainment Weekly open the
magazine first look Judd Apatow film
coming out in four months why can't we
do something similar to that they have
an exclusive asset and exclusive image
these are assets these are files so but
you know what about the small phone
maker you know that doesn't have the
stars in their film you know that
there's no you gotta find a hook because
I there's nothing necessarily super
exciting or just like wow here's like
this film that I've never heard of by
filmmakers I've never heard
and yeah radiation here this exclusive
first look it turns like here's our
movie folks they're like is that really
gonna work for I will work will work if
you if you're tiny and you don't have a
names does it have to be traditional
media it can be someone that you know
that has a very good online following
that can put your thing out there that
might even be bigger than traditional
media let's let's let's just think about
it right so you know through the
festival you know through Holly shorts
out I have a few friends that are you
they have massive companies you know
like I don't know New York Film Academy
or a similar similar brand that's got
some credibility to it you know that
that's a film school or something you
can tap into that audience its audience
these are people potential targets that
will see the film you don't have to go
traditional media to give an exclusive
you guys do this you know I saw a
filmmaker do that recently a very big
name lend his name to to Kodak and just
be like you know check don't give up on
film yet now that's yes that's a tough
but anyhow it's a big campaign and it's
like that's not traditional media you
know so it doesn't have to be
traditional media you gotta just gotta
have a good brand that reaches people
and then that's willing to vouch for you
by offering this up to them testimonial
wise you know what I'm going to make the
main just I'm getting from the whole
thing it's just like it's not history
it's like it's like picking yourself as
this big entity absolutely also you know
partnering barring and absolutely
reaching you know these other companies
and other organizations and other people
that can help spread the message quicker
and absolutely like that so it's all
about that bass of the game it's the
compound it's the compound factor you
want to reach as many people as possible
you already have friends you have
already have a role rolodex and database
of people that work at some of these
companies since we don't have the budget
of a Disney to buy you know to do a
billboard campaign national billboard
campaign we got to work with what we got
we got to offer them some kind of ad
space we've got to offer them something
in exchange for agreements and then you
put a
you're putting your media plan together
right so your media plan just like the
big guys do it's a it's a media campaign
you put your one sheet and say we're
going to have you do this you do that in
exchange for this and then you have your
timeline for your action points skipping
ahead to the QA what type of a host
should we would be looking for and what
type of style would have an interview
style is appropriate for an independent
film Q&A well it just depends on the
content of the film if you're dealing
with a comedy you want someone a little
more lighthearted this is a documentary
film you want someone that's comes from
the academia or someone that's got some
cooking out it's got to be someone with
cloud no matter what um but you don't
want someone that's overbearing and
self-serving on the Q&A and it's gonna
just hog the microphone and talk about
themselves I believe it not to seen it
before you know ever i've had clients on
panels and you know the moderator is
leading the discussion he's like this is
what I do this is what I did well in my
project I did this and it got to be
careful you got to look at their
experience you gotta see where they
spoken at before have they done this
before I have a Q&A before so not
someone to self serving someone that
kind of fits the genre of the film that
you're presenting and you know someone
that's got a little bit of bit of buzz
factor so you can help announced that
and you know need to build and I some
other folks to come out you know but it
it is definitely a risk still um a lot
of the folks that we worked with before
are you know people that are that host
traditional shows right on television
and sometimes they want to do something
that's beyond their traditional thing
you reach the independent film community
so a lot of the people that are on TV
sometimes want to find other avenues and
would be surprised a lot of the hosts
want to do stuff for supporting
supporting indie film that's another
thing that you got to reach to as well
as I think it's a message point to
support indie film you know that's very
key that's why we were asking about the
brands and the underdogs and the
unknowns I think that's going to be a
key selling point is this is an
independent film and it's it
a one way to run at a theater and you
gotta you gotta show support studios now
bless them all they're doing is tempo
movies 80 100 million dollar budgets you
know there's no room right now for the
independence I mean there's plenty of
room this creative ways for us to you
know continue surviving but right now
it's everybody wants to make the tent
poles at the same time to get a little
tire that you hired every in development
and every independent filmmaker view
life support and he feels more because
you know no no at the end of the day
this is it this is this is our shot you
know this is a shot to make the mark you
know I think it's fine I don't think so
I don't think so because the big guys
are doing it too and they're doing it
other that they're in our faces more
than we're in their faces we may be the
anti-violence we gotta flee gotta listen
this is it we have we have a very short
window they had a slate of 20 to 30
films that they're coming out with Bill
recoup you know you know I mean they
have a movie that it's a stinker 200
million dollar budget and then in a few
weeks after they have a film that's the
highest grossing of all time and made
654 million worldwide and counting so
they're gonna be fine you know so but
the independent filmmakers I just took
out their mortgage to make this indie
film we got listen there are no rules we
got to go all out we got to tap
everybody Bradley support especially if
it's a great content and at the end of
the day if you put it out there and
everyone supports you and your
filmmakers are behind you it's gonna
have legs you know people are going to
keep talking about it and then you have
to map out your phase-two strategy
you